En route, pour le grand voyage.
Si vous avez vu "Stranger things". Vous avez sans doute déja entendu parler de l'isolation sensorielle
Si vous l'avez pas vu, restez quand même
Parce que ça va vous intéresser... Et en plus je vais pas vous spoiler, promis
L'isolation sensorielle c'est le genre de sujet qu'il faut mieux avoir tester pour pouvoir en parler et que l'on comprend mieux quand on voit vraiment de quoi il s'agit
Alors on va y aller et on discutera sur place, mais avant, faut que je me mette en tenue
Transformation
Sérieux ?
Ah bah voila ! Allez, on est parti !
Ouais alors par contre l'isolation sensorielle c'est sans maillot de bain hein...
Le principe de l'isolation sensorielle c'est de mettre tous ses sens au repos
pour que le cerveau est un minimum de stimulation et puisse atteindre un état de conscience intermédiaire.
Pour supprimer un maximum de sollicitations extérieures on se place dans un caisson,
dans lequel le noir et le silence sont complet et qui est rempli d'une eau saturée en sel de magnésium
dans laquelle le corps flotte très haut à la surface sans avoir aucun effort à fournir.
Et pour éviter le frottement du tissu, on enlève le maillot !
- Je fais quoi là ?
- Bah va te laver grand sale !
- Ok, la douche
Avant d'aller flotter, on se lave. Comme à la piscine, avec un savon au Ph neutre.
Petite astuce confort ; les bouchons pour éviter d'avoir du sel qui rentre dans les oreilles.
Bon, mais avant de se mettre dans le bain, un peu d'histoire...
L'intérêt pour l'isolation sensorielle elle date des années 50.
Le premier caisson a été mis au point dans le cadre de travaux sur la conscience par John Lilly
Un neuroscientifique à la fois très sérieux et... complètement tsoin tsoin !
Il a par exemple essayé d'apprendre à parler à des dauphins
et il a mené un certain nombre de ses expériences sous LSD ou sous kétamine
D'ailleurs les deux sont peut-être un peu liés...
Au début, le modèle de caisson d'isolation sensorielle était moyennement confortable
Mais ça c'est amélioré au fil du temps pour arriver au modèle que l'on connait aujourd'hui
Le principe a continué à être utilisé à travers les décennies suivantes,
comme moyen d'atteindre une sorte de nirvana hippie, puis par des médecins
pour traiter des troubles anxieux, par des artistes pour développer leur créativité,
par des sportifs pour préparer des compétitions ou récupérer après.
Aujourd'hui, il y a des centres de flottaison un peu partout dans le monde.
Si vous vous renseignez sur le sujet, vous lirez sûrement que l'isolation sensorielle
permet à votre cerveau de produire des ondes thêta c'est-à-dire de se caler sur le rythme caractéristique
de la phase intermédiaire entre une phase d'éveil et une phase de sommeil.
Alors, j'en ai parlé avec un médecin chercheur spécialiste des neurosciences et...
Bon, disons qu'à priori il n'y a pas de vrai recherche scientifique sur le sujet
et que l'électrophysiologie cérébrale c'est un peu plus compliqué que ça.
Les premières minutes sont un peu difficiles parce qu'il faut se faire à l'idée qu'on va flotter comme ça,
dans le noir, à respirer de la vapeur pendant une heure
Mais petit à petit je me suis laissé aller, j'ai trouvé ma position et c'était vraiment paisible
C'est un peu comme être en apesanteur mais avec les organes génitaux qui baignent dans le sel.
Bon à un moment, je me suis gratté les sourcils... c'était pas une bonne idée !
Je saurais pas trop dire si j'ai dormi ou pas apparemment c'est habituel
mais en tout cas j'ai eu des espèces d'hallucination visuelle
Nan nan, en vrai rien d'aussi méchant que ça.
Plutôt, comme ces espèces de formes lumineuses qui apparaissent quand on regarde dans le noir
Bon bah là pareil sauf que c'était beaucoup plus net.
Mais non mais pas du tout mais qu'est-ce que c'est que ça ?! Romain !
En gros, j'ai vu des yeux flotter dans le noir et les pièces d'une maison en enfilade
comme si je me déplacer dans un jeu vidéo en vue subjective
Allez savoir pourquoi !
Non cherchez pas, c'est juste une façon de parler...
Ah oui, à un moment il ma aussi semblé entendre un groupe de rock répéter dans la pièce d'à côté
Bon en fait, je me suis renseigné, il n'y avait pas de groupe de rock dans la pièce d'à côté
En tout cas, j'ai vécu une expérience très particulière et je suis sorti extrêmement relaxé
Voila, ma séance vient de se terminer, je suis totalement détendu, j'ai perdu complètement la notion du temps
et la notion de l'espace pendant l'heure que ça a duré. Allez, on rentre à la maison maintenant !
Bon alors qu'est-ce-qu'on retient de tout ça ? Scientifiquement parlant,
il n'y a pas grand chose qui tient la route. A part une étude Suédoise qui a montré
que c'était efficace sur le stress, sur l'anxiété et même sur la dépression.
C'est déjà pas mal !
Moi ce que je me suis dis, c'est que si les premières minutes dans le caisson sont aussi difficiles,
c'est parce qu'on est plus habitué à lâcher prise et dans l'histoire c'est peut être ça le plus précieux.
Mon camarade neuroscientifique et moi on est tombé d'accord sur un point,
l'isolation sensorielle c'est un super moyen de relaxation
Parce que ça permet de se relâcher à la fois  physiquement et psychologiquement,
sans rien avoir à faire et en étant tout seul avec soi-même
C'est rare ! Et se qui en fait une expérience vraiment étonnante, c'est que contrairement à se qu'on pourrait croire
moins on n'est stimulé physiquement plus notre corps se repose et plus notre cerveau est actif.
Chez certain ça stimule la créativité, chez d'autre ça favorise l'introspection,
chez d'autre encore ça fait apparaître des yeux qui flottent dans les airs
Chacun réagit différemment et en retire quelque chose de personnel
D'ailleurs si vous avez testé ou si vous avez envie de le faire après avoir vu cette vidéo,
revenez me raconter ça dans les commentaire, ça fera plaisir !
En attendant, DTC c'est fini pour aujourd'hui, on se retrouve la semaine prochaine pour une nouvelle vidéo
d'ici là, mettez-vous bien et surtout, portez-vous bien !